Lee in this house we're all 49ers oh
yeah of course
right right you know of course and then
um for me though I was like go I don't
know anything about it but I was like
Kansas City because of my friend Eric
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I get that because of
you
well then that's great but that doesn't
mean then I have to accept dick pictures
like we can we can find a middle ground
all right you're right I think for
example this conversation where I say
thank you for supporting the Kansas City
Chiefs yeah no you were actually there
at the game correct yeah I was there I
was there Bobby
yeah and now when you cuz I remember
what in the game when you we San
Francisco was winning right most of you
guys were behind what were you feeling
you know I was feeling optimistic but
you know they were they're a really good
team so I knew that we would have to do
something fairly fairly impressive to
come back and win and at one point I
leaned over to Lindsey and I said if we
don't pick this third-down up or we're
done and then that's when Patrick
mahomes hit Tyree kill for 45 yards Wow
yeah I remember that and then when that
happened because I can only imagine
sitting next to you when that happened
what were you doing screaming yeah I got
up and I walked very fast back and forth
in a very aggressive way that's right
because you're in a box probably you're
not with the people or I am god no yeah
your answer was like no I was with I was
sitting with the Commissioner of
football Roger Goodell actually Wow okay
I realize okay I get it you're fancy all
right well no it's not that's not why
that's not why I was sitting I was
sitting with him because he had invited
me a few years earlier to come to the
Super Bowl to sit with him and his
daughters and his wife and I told him no
that I wouldn't come to the Super Bowl
until the Chiefs were in it and then
five years six years later the Chiefs
were in it and I called him and said
rain check please yeah Wow
so you're now pacing back and forth
mm-hmm and then all of a sudden you know
you guys start
I'm catching up what was the others did
I I don't remember yeah you have to
understand I had been through two games
where we were behind before and a couple
games with Patrick mahomes as our
quarterback now that feel different when
you're behind it used to not feel like
there was any chance we could catch up
but with him as the quarterback it now
feels different you I don't think your
followers care about sports don't they
just don't make fun of you know they
don't know I'm a big Arsenal fan I love
sports
you're a big what fan oh well the only
sport that really matters Arsenal oh
yeah it's a football team out of so all
right you know maybe we don't take
breaks
[Laughter]
commercial break while they make some
sort of plan no soccer we just keep
playing okay Bobby all right bud but
anyway hey uh how many podcasts do you
have I have two you have this one I have
this one I do one with the Freak
Anderson too you know
yeah what's his deal what do you mean
he's a freak he's ready why did you call
him a freak he is a freaky kind of a guy
he's a comic you know all comics are
kind of free oh yeah